fuite de laboratoire chinois ou
phénomène naturel le mystère de
l'origine de la covid est comme un feu
de brousse dès qu'on le croit éteint un
nouvel incendie déclare VF
mardi sur Fox News le FBI n'avait
pourtant aucune preuve concrète à offrir
au public pour appuyer ses propos mais
tout ça n'a pas manqué d'irriter le
gouvernement chinois
la ministre chinoise a même avancé une
autre version des faits le virus
pourrait avoir été fabriqué dans le
laboratoire d'une base militaire
américaine située dans l'État du
Marylène
à son tour la Maison Blanche a réagit
on fait plus le temps passe et plus le
mystère s'épaissit on s'entend sur une
chose les premiers cas de covid ont été
observés dans ce marché d'annemo
exotiques de One en Chine mais ce qu'ils
sont le résultat d'un contact entre un
humain et un animal sauvage ou le
résultat d'une fuite de virus hors de ce
laboratoire de one spécialisé dans
l'étude des coronavirus
le problème tout le monde veut des
réponses claires mais personne ne
véritables pièces à conviction à
présenter
selon l'OMS près de 7 millions de
personnes sont décédées depuis
l'apparition du virus à One en 2019 ici
normand Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal